you know I was thinking about the other
day yeah and the only reason why I bring
you on this podcast so we could talk
about this [ __ ] about your poor life
choices about one woman that you should
have kept in your I have never oh my God
we're gonna go there we're gonna go
there yeah I have never been so
disappointed in somebody's life choices
until I met you
but for me honestly when people do
things that I don't agree with normally
I don't care yeah just because like it's
their life it's your life you do
whatever you want with it but you made
the biggest mistake of your life all
right well okay I think I made a good
decision
oh yeah because it's you know morally it
makes sense financially it doesn't
alright so a little bit of background
information here who he's referring to
was somebody that I dated who was uh
let's just say she came from a very
wealthy background right and uh let's
just say let's just say she could have
been the princess of Persia she could
have fed me and you taking care of my
whole family and it wouldn't have dented
anything in her [ __ ] bank account
that's true that's true but long story
short basically it got to the point
where she kind of gave me like in a
ultimatum of like you know 3-year plan
of okay within the next year I want to
be married within two years Oh No
within one year she wants to be engaged
within two she wants to be married and
within three she wants to have kids was
how long were you guys together before
this ultimatum came around though um I
don't know like a year and a half or so
or I don't know two years alibied wasn't
she enough time I wasn't really keeping
track no but like for me is I don't
appreciate when somebody imposes their
will on me like that because it was just
more of a situation of now okay I told
her I said I can't make any promises
because even if I do I don't know what's
gonna happen from now until you know
next month next year two years from now
all I can say is I can say if we keep
going down the path that we're going
down then that's what it'll probably
lead to but but she wanted definites
yeah yeah it was like
I want you to tell me that this is
what's gonna happen and I'm like I can't
tell you that nobody can tell you that
who the [ __ ] knows what the future holds
for us so you weren't you weren't sure
that that was the woman that you wanted
to marry even after you found out that
she was a crazy rich Asian do basically
that's the story she was like she was a
crazy she that's where she's from yeah I
mean but but the thing is is like you
know I think initially when we first
started dating she was trying to not
make it so obvious she's trying to kind
of hide I would have never known oh yeah
I absolutely don't ooh earth yeah very
sweet yeah yeah and like to me when I
met her the the couple of times I would
have never thought that she came from
money because number one she didn't
flaunt it right
she didn't behave as somebody who came
from money so like yeah when I met her I
thought she was just some average girl
that just worked on out obviously yeah I
mean I I really thought the same thing
and in the sense of like I didn't know
she came from that type of money and I
feel like she kind of had her
experiences with that where people would
try to use her or or like get to what
are you saying bro this is your fantasy
that we're talking about through me
right I don't even remember her name I
don't care about her name remember I
just I just saw his [ __ ] what do you
call I call her lotto
it's your winning lotto ticket not after
the fact though by the way I found this
out after the fact I had no clue and
then he said this is the worst decision
that I've ever made him like no but I
mean here's here's the thing man
is um I told you about this too is like
when she had brought up that
conversation is when we were preparing
the lookbook shoot for secret society
that was so a lot of [ __ ] was going on
and you know we had a pretty ambitious
project with that so in order to get
everything organized and make sure that
everything was going to be what we were
hoping we could make there was a lot of
time and energy that went into that but
for her even knowing that that wasn't
the best time to talk about it and she
even prefaced it by saying that like
saying yeah I know this is not the best
time to bring this up to you but and
then blah blah blah and I was like this
is something this is something else I
gotta get solved all of our problems she
could have so we were struggling so bad
I believe she even offered yeah she did
to help financially support it and she
hold on a second this is what she said
that got me the most this is where I
started to hate you as a human being she
said you could take whatever and you
don't even have to pay me back and I
said wow what a saint and you said I'm
leaving you are a bad person no I mean
here's the thing man it's just you know
as as a man and as a principled man you
know it's just I there was no way that I
was even willing to entertain that idea
or that offer it was just more from like
for me it was just like I appreciate the
the moral support and and the thought
that you have about that that you would
even be willing to offer that but I made
that very clear it's like there's no way
that I'm taking your money you know for
any reason and all I really need is for
you to be in my corner and just give me
the moral support damn dude you sound
like a fruity ass movie
weather what a great choice would have
been okay I wanted in cold hard hats and
I wanted to support my really good
friend David because he stopped doing
YouTube for two years and he still has
the same spending habits and then he's
gonna live with this and all he has to
do is clean toilets and make food that's
it yeah I mean but you know it is what
it is man like but was the ultimatum the
only reason why you didn't want to be
with her just because because like that
that was kind of like I think it showed
me a different shade of her then I had
him previously seen and and that was
like her kind of and this is this is how
I feel maybe she felt there for
about it but I just felt that she was
kind of saying what mattered to me was
not as significant as what's important
to her right now you know because the
thing is she could have waited like
literally a couple of weeks a month
whatever to have that conversation once
we got finished with it at least then
she knows okay that's off my chest
that's off my mind now we can have this
conversation which would I what I felt
would have been more reasonable but in
the thick of it when I would cuz cuz
look at this too man
you know that when I I quit my job to
start this [ __ ] right yeah and then so I
was living off my savings and it was
obviously getting pretty tough right now
and so I was trying to really conserve
my money not go out be indoors all day
just [ __ ] working on this [ __ ]
talking with the factories whatever and
then it really started to take a toll on
me and then on top of that we had to
look book shoot so and you know that
that sure was no easy task either man
there were so many moving parts to that
so like she knew all of this was going
on because we would talk obviously you
know we're together for that long but
still her desire and her needs
pretty much outweighed all that and it I
almost took it as an indirect way of her
telling me like yeah I know that's
important to you but it really doesn't
matter because this matters more right
now you know because what difference
would it have made if we had that
conversation two weeks a month two
months even after the fact right because
we were already together for a while at
that point but yeah I mean I'm sure I
have my thoughts and my feelings about
it and she might disagree with what I'm
saying right now but really doesn't
matter I feel like what happened
happened for a reason and I have no
regrets about it you know I have a great
you were thinking about the life of
private Jetson I miss her I miss you so
much I miss you so much
Tiffany names start with s ah Stephanie
Oh III won't say I would say okay we
can't say her name yeah yeah just for
just for privacy reasons but [ __ ]
help
well I only met her a couple of times
that's no target of hallo you knew this
girl inside I liked and she had a heart
of gold and she would this she did she
was with you you trash bag she had a
great heart of gold oh man I miss her so
much dude I remember the times where she
and I just sat across the table didn't
talk [ __ ] what great dude hey hey I'm
like hey and then we'd be like what's up
no but I mean I I don't know man I feel
like everybody has their own agendas and
priorities in life you know and at that
point for me it was about the brand I'm
not gonna say that she didn't matter to
me and my wife gave us body for the
brand you didn't care enough about the
brand I know man and hey you know I'm
kidding dude I I'm not gonna say this on
the podcast but I I got pretty kind of
fed up with with that her like offering
me yeah I know what that feels like
though just because I'm pretty sure in
her case she wasn't thinking like oh
like I need and her she was prep she was
trying to be helpful
mm-hmm but there's something about being
able to do stuff on your own with your
own will in your own power and your own
money yeah like it doesn't feel the same
and it almost feels like a handout you
don't want to [ __ ] hand exactly man
exactly I mean that's and I wasn't
raised like that you know what I mean
like you know our family didn't we
weren't rich
we were [ __ ] poor so I had to work
for everything that I wanted in life
yeah that's just the way I'm built you
know and so I threw that all away I
remember a dress girl had really big
titties and I could have lived in those
oh my god I would have just I wouldn't I
would have just [ __ ] held my tongue
and just rested in those balloons and
you could have floated away to happiness
a rich man a very rich man who didn't
have to do anything but not a woman you
know what the thing is though
like she would talk to my friends like
because she in her mind could not figure
out why I was so reluctant to give that
type of commitment that she wanted so
she would go to my friends and like kind
of and you know that she knows if she
talks to them about it that they're
gonna talk to me about it you know what
I'm of course yeah default exactly so
she would kind of go to them and be like
yeah I don't understand why you know
Edie doesn't want to commit like that
because you know we we get along and you
know like I have money and I'm like if
we get married and that you know that
would also be his like what's mine is
his but I think from the very beginning
I made it so clear like I don't give a
[ __ ] about how much money you have yeah
it seems like for her she's probably
used to that type of treatment and it's
kind of interesting in her case where
she doesn't want to be judged or develop
relationships for that before that's her
trump card right so that's exactly
that's the thing man at the end of it I
felt like she was almost hanging that
[ __ ] over my head it's like why wouldn't
you want to be yeah I have yeah exactly
she's talking to the wrong person yeah
yeah and that I got [ __ ] insulted by
that I'm like dude said that to me you
do it like let me think about it right
where she said they should listen I
don't get it yeah what's mine would be
yours but why don't you say in the first
page yes a long time why buy the
engagement do you buy your own give it
to me and I surprise you with something
you already know that I have because I
can't buy you something really and then
you buy the house right and the car and
then you go to work and then I put a
ribbon on the house and you didn't know
and I cut it saying it's happy about
that I don't know how this relationship
works out but I'm willing to figure it
out I'm making sacrifices so yeah I'm
gonna be a stay-at-home dad don't you
worry about six-pack I don't give up hey
you know what man like teach their own I
know some people out there can live like
that I can't like if I don't have that
type of like drive and ambition in my
life I just would feel like it's just
hard to end up being with somebody that
you just
click with in that sense yeah yeah cuz
at the end of the day man we always talk
about the Shinto you can't leave with
the money that you have on this earth
anyway so what does it [ __ ] exactly
and for me it's like what matters more
is about really doing and trying to
accomplish something that's meaningful
to me and like I was saying at that time
in place and especially in our
relationship I would have hoped and even
assumed that she would understand how
important it was to me especially
because she even made an offer member
about moving to her home countries right
yeah the biggest offer yeah and I said
if you know me you already know what my
answer to that is we just started the
clothing brand - at that point yeah well
no no it was right before that it was
wrong oh no no no I'm sorry I'm sorry I
think it was just yeah after we launched
it yeah I think I think that's what it
was I don't know the timelines Luisi
from the time well the point of that was
that during that time like she should
have known like yo I just started
something that I'm very passionate about
yeah you know I'm not gonna leave it
exactly and and to know the sacrifices
that I made for it you know what I'm
gonna bring David with me like they she
even de even offer that on the tables
like so you're gonna get David place to
write like yeah I can come Mariel speak
Taiwanese Mandarin like she needs a
place the boat that you miss oh that's a
great film is called the boat that I
miss the boat that you miss and it's not
huge about the me but like I said this
was it let me get a number bro jackass
poor choices no I mean it's just like
you know once once I'm done it's done
like there's there's no cuz here's the
thing man yeah and I'm sure you can
attest it as to is like when a
relationship ends right especially if
you guys didn't start as friends trying
to kind of now go backwards into a
friend zone and trying to find out and
establish that and define
that no my I saw your vagina we can't go
back I saw your vagina it's not exactly
it's it's like Din evitable accelerating
the inevitable just fast-forwarding it
you know like let's skip all that
[ __ ] [ __ ] and just boom it's
gonna be done anyway yeah yeah I feel a
lot of people don't understand that
though yeah a lot of people say well
that's kind of heartless for you to cut
ties with somebody that you developed a
relationship over for for many years or
whatever months and stuff right
but for me is how I see this is if I die
tomorrow you would still move on right
right right
all right you would you would end up
with somebody else you'll have kids and
you'll eventually forget about me you're
right and so whether I choose to be a
part of your life or not your life will
still be better without me so it doesn't
matter that's what I'm saying ultimately